Sylvain Desjardins.
- Hé, on a réussi! On a réussi!
(soupir)
Ha! ha! ha! Ah!
♪ ♪ ♪
!!!!
I'm so happy to see you!
- Happy to see you.
- La nouvelle vie du Dr Wali
et de sa famille ne s'est pas
déroulée comme prévu jusqu'à
maintenant. Au contraire.
Deux adultes et sept enfants,
entassés dans deux chambres
tel pendant plus de deux
mois, sans savoir ce qui les
attend, après avoir passé trois
mois de terreur et d'errance
en Afghanistan et au Pakistan.
hélène lescelleur, capitaine à
la retraite, Forces armées can.,
il y aurait eu des puces de lit,
il y aurait eu vraiment
de l'insalubrité présente dansùs
afghanes, en fait, ont été
envoyées. Ce qu'on a trouvé un
petit peu scandaleux lorsqu'on
pense que, dans le fond, on
souhaitait que les familles
arrivent ici au Canada
dans des conditions qui sont
favorables, dans le fond,
à leur installation.
- La capitaine à la retraite
Hélène LeScelleur a joué un rôle
central dans l'organisation
du départ du Dr Wali
et de sa famille d'Afghanistan.
Elle est estomaquée par
la piètre qualité des services
offerts par le mandataire
des autorités canadiennes.
- La nourriture n'a jamais été
offerte dans des quantités
suffisantes pour la famille.
Donc, c'est pas rare qu'on a dû
transférer de l'argent à Dr Wali
pour qu'il puisse faire
des achats supplémentaires
pour combler les besoins
de sa famille.
- Le Dr Walileleleleleleles
personnes responsables de gérer
leur accueil et leur dossier de
réinstallation étaient souvent
incompétentes, irascibles
et parfogrgrgrgrgrgrgressives.
Le ministre fédéral responsable
se dit lui aussi atterrépapapapt
la tenue d'une enquête, non
seulement auprès de l'organisme
Polycultural, à Toronto,
mais aussi chez les autres
mandataires à travers le pays.
Le Dr Wali et d'autres réfugiér
une lettre aux autorités,
qui fait état des problèmes
qu'ils rencontrent, incluant
des épisodes de discriminationà.
- On se doit d'être transparent,
on se doit d'être accueillant
dans tout ce processus-là.
Donc, c'est important d'être
sensible au niveau culturel,
mais d'être surtout sensible
que ces familles-là viennent
de quitter un pays en guerre,
et ce qu'on leur offre à leur
arrivée ici, c'est prati
le même genre de traitement.
- Si le gouvernement prévoit
effectuer des changements à son
système d'accueil
il n'a pas encore établi
d'échéancier pour y arriver.